Okay.
In this video we'll see
different potential choices
for the activation function
of the neuron.
So we've seen previously the
computation that is made in the neuron,
and we started to
involve this Gi function,
which we call the activation function.
So here we'll just see different popular
choices for activation functions in the
neural networks
at first choice is to simply use
a linear activation function.
Uh,
so in this case,
the activation function g takes it's
pre activation and simply outputs it.
So if we were to plot the
this activation function,
you'd get a straight line like this.
Uh,
so it doesn't perform any
squashing of the input that is, uh,
it takes the input and
reproduces it. So, uh,
it won't be upper bounded or lower
bounded. And partly for that reason,
it's not a very interesting,
it doesn't introduce any nonlinearities
in the computation of the neuron,
which might be a useful for performing
more complicated computations
and more interesting choices. The
sigmoid activation function. Um,
so it takes this form a, which,
so we'll sometime note it as a,
with the acronym, a, s,
I, g, m and a for short.
And it's simply takes deep reactivation
and it computes this formula here.
So it's one over one plus the
exponential of minus the pre activation.
And so if we draw this function,
what we see is that it will squash the
neurons a pre activation between zero and
one. We see that all output values
are between zero and one here.
And so the bigger the p activation,
the more it will saturate towards one
and the smallest activation towards minus
infinite, the more it will
saturate towards zero instead.
So this neuron is always positive,
uh,
because it's always strictly
greater than zero. It's a bounded,
that is the, uh, uh, uh,
output of the neuron.
The activation of the neuron cannot be
smaller end zero nor greater than one.
And uh, this activation function
is a strictly increasing.
That is the bigger the activation,
the higher the activation
of the neuron will be.
And other populations choices.
The hyperbolic tangent a or tench.
So it's a t, a n, h for short,
and it's a slightly more complicated.
It also involves some exponential.
So one form is this form here,
why it's the exponential reactivation
minus the exponential of minus EPA
activation divided by the sum of
the exponential of the reactivation,
plus the exponential of
minus the pre activation.
And a,
it can also be written in this form,
which is more convenient because
it computes just one exponential.
So a which is we used here, so it might
be more computationally efficient. And uh,
this is just obtained by multiplying by
the exponential of the pre activation,
the numerator and the denominator
of this formula here. Uh,
so if you plot this function,
we see that now we get an output which
is strained between minus one and one.
So this neuron will say that
it squashes the neurons, uh,
pre activation.
So this should be pre activation
here between minus one and one,
so it can be positive or negative.
Uh,
it's also bounded similarly like the uh,
sigmoid activation function and
it has also strictly increasing.
And a final popular choice for the
activation function is what is called the
rectified linear activation function.
So we know that Recklin for short and
it's simply the maximum between zero and
the pre activation. And so if we
plotted, we get a straight line here,
like a linear function. If the input
is positive is greater than zero,
and otherwise it's just zero. So it's
a straight line, a horizontal line,
uh, and if the input is
negative, it always outputs zero.
So here it's only valid by
below, uh, below by zero.
So it's always non negative. Uh, it's uh,
not upper bounded because the
greater the p activation here,
the greater the output will
be. So this can grow, uh, uh,
this always grows again, uh, converge
to the output, can converse to, uh,
or diverged towards infinite.
If the input goes towards the,
uh, towards, uh, the infinity and, um,
and in practice we see that it tends
to give neurons that are sparse,
that have sparse activity activities.
What we mean by that is that it tends to
get neurons that are often exactly zero,
which was not the case for the
sigmoid or the tach. The similar,
the attention need to have
a pre activations that are,
uh, exactly a particular value. So in
the sigmoid case, to get zero, you need,
it needs to be minus infinite.
So it doesn't happen really.
And for the times to be equal to zero in
the pre activation needs to be exactly
zero. In this case, there's
this whole rage of [inaudible],
which are the output exactly zero. So
for, for this reason, we often get,
uh,
a zeros as the activation of the
neuron across many different inputs.
And so we'll say that for that reason,
this neuron will have a sparse
activations or sparse activities.
And so those are the
four different choices,
public choices for the
activation function of a neuron.